that was exciting yeah no it was
annoying
i enjoyed it it's a tale as old as time
bickering
longing stares the angst build up by now
we can all spot the markings of an epic
on-screen romance
and the after series tessa young and
hard and scott are no exception
so far only two out of the five books
have hit the big screen
but that was enough to notice some
pretty key changes in the characters and
even the plot
in this video we'll be going over all
those shocking differences
did the changes make the movies better
or worse than the books
let's find out what's the first thing
that comes to mind when you think about
hart and scott
well your answer probably depends on
whether or not you've read the novels or
watched the films
in the book author anna todd definitely
took his broody angsty attitude to
another level
he has intense anger issues from past
trauma and can't get through a sentence
without dropping an f-bomb
but in the movies hardin brought more
mystery to the screen than anger
whatever our souls are made of his and
mine are the same
his movie character could definitely be
a little arrogant but his overall book
attitude was toned down
could this be because his behavior in
the book was a little too toxic and
inappropriate to translate
on screen nothing screams bad boy like
black leather tattoos and piercings
and no surprise here hardin has all
three or at least he was supposed to
in the written version of the after
series hardin is basically littered with
tattoos
and piercings and it's why tessa looks
completely bizarre next to him
but just like his personality his look
was completely muted on screen
there were no piercings for actor hero
tiffin and his tattoos were only really
noticeable when he didn't have a shirt
on what are you doing i'm going swimming
instead he looked pretty generic
attractive
but generic they did get his wardrobe
spot on so we'll give them that
josephine langford did a perfect job of
bringing tessa young's kindness and
innocence to life
not to mention she looks basically
identical to the way she's described in
the novels
but there's one huge difference between
book and movie tessa
her university major it may not seem
like a huge change
but her being an english major is the
catalyst to her relationship with landon
and hardin
instead in the movie she's a business
and econ major who
at the end of the first film thinks
about potentially transferring into the
english program
what's your major tesla i'm thinking
business or maybe
economics the after book series isn't
just heated because of harden's attitude
if you know you know tessa and hardin's
relationship is super intimate in the
novels and
super descriptive after all the whole
plot is based on her inexperience in bed
wait
are you a virgin there's a whole bet
about it
and while that's still true in the
movies those steamy scenes were toned
down to a more wholesome
pg-13 version some fans might have been
disappointed but it probably helped them
expand their audience
speaking of the bet it's a little
different in the book than it is in the
film
on paper the bet hardin makes with his
friends is that he can take tess's
virginity and prove it to them
and that's what he does proof and all
it's a little harsh
and makes you question whether or not
you want tessa and harden to end up
together
maybe that's why they made the bet a
little more forgiving in the movie
hardin instead bets that he can make
tessa fall in love with him
he just doesn't plan on falling in love
himself
you don't think i can make it happen
make her fall in love with me
like we said before the book was much
more r-rated and overall
uncomfortable in certain parts including
the whole idea that hardin keeps proof
of his time together with tessa
in order to claim his money he gives up
the sheets and contraceptives from his
night with tessa
in the movie there isn't any need for
physical evidence and it's all by word
of mouth
not that that makes the situation any
less heartbreaking for tessa but it's
certainly less traumatizing and toxic
what exactly did you tell them then it's
nothing
one of the biggest character changes has
to be tristan tristan is the love
interest of tessa's roommate steph but
there's one difference between book
tristan and movie tristan
their gender in the book tristan is a
boy but in the movie
she's a girl while that doesn't change
anything plot-wise there was a reason
for the change
anna todd told ibt that it was about
being more diverse
and the change makes perfect sense to
her we can get you into all the best
places even without a fake
no problem we wouldn't blame you if you
let out a groan when you hear the name
carol young also known as tessa's mother
in the novels
she probably could be considered a
villain she's extremely controlling of
tessa's life
and even threatens to disown her when
she doesn't go along with her big life
plan
thanks to her we get to see tessa and
harden living together so it's not all
bad
but in the movie we really get to see
more of the realistic mother-daughter
bond they've grown with one another over
the years
she might not agree with tessa's choices
but she's both more understanding and
respectful of her decisions
i'm sorry i'm sorry too
there is a slight change that doesn't
really have an impact on the story but
anna todd again thought it was important
to be more inclusive in the movie than
her writing was
that's why tessa's professor sato was
cast as a woman instead of a man
there you have it that's the power of a
good
book molly samuels might be more
annoying than carol young
might cute dress
she's the constant instigator between
tessa and hardin and whenever she's in
the room there's constant tension
she's even the reason tessa finds out
about the bet however the movie just
doesn't give her the same screen time
she got in the books
we get to see so much more of how
deceptive she can be on paper
missed opportunity or did the film just
save us a whole lot of frustration
landon is tess's rock throughout the
series and eventually ends up becoming
close with harden too
so we're brothers
while his character is very similar to
his book version there was a change to
his physical appearance
in the novel he's described as
resembling david beckham but in the
movies they've decided to reimagine him
as a person of color
the diversity might be the best change
anna todd and the directors decided to
include in the films
the after book ending is a huge
cliffhanger and must have tortured
people who had to wait in order to get
their hands on after we collided
but the film ended more on a note of
closure while they both end after the
aftermath of tessa finding out about the
bet
in the movie tessa received an apology
note in the form of a hardin's essay
this is what hardin turned out i think
it was actually written more for you
than it was for me we then see tessa
head to the lake to meet hardin
the book doesn't have that type of
closure
what's a young adult novel without a
love triangle the after series is
definitely not lacking those that's for
sure
at least in the novels zed hardin's
friend is also in on the bet put up
against tessa but
also ends up developing feelings for her
however in the films
he's barely mentioned and doesn't play
much of a role in hardin and tessa's
relationship
well well look at the cat dragged in
instead of zed
the movie decided to focus more on
trevor but even then they waited to
introduce him
he doesn't pop up in the storyline until
the after we collided film
whereas he's in a lot of the first novel
he is played by dylan sprouse so that
could be a big reason why they wanted to
focus on this love triangle
instead of the one that includes zed hey
good to see you how are you
speaking of trevor he has a pretty
interesting nickname given to him by
hardin in the books
like we said hardin's vocabulary isn't
the shiniest
and after we collided he always refers
to trevor as
whereas in the movie he only gets the
chance to call him by his nickname once
like we mentioned before trevor doesn't
make an appearance in the films until
after we collided
this is because tessa doesn't land her
internship until the second film
but in the novels thanks to the scots
she gets hired advanced publishing in
the first book
welcome to vance publishing that also
means we don't get to meet other
characters like christian and kim
until the second film because of how the
after movie ending differed from the
book
the movie opening of after we collided
is pretty confusing
ironically it's in line with the after
we collided novel but doesn't make sense
for fans of just the movie
the film opens with them being broken up
but how did that happen if the final
moments had them at the lake reconciling
why haven't you called me i've texted
you a hundred times you haven't replied
despite the changes that were made to
our favorite characters we know that
anna todd tried her best to bring
fans the movie they deserve do you think
that the changes made tessa and hardin's
story better or worse
was there anything that should have
stayed the same let us know in the
comment section below
make sure to hit that subscribe button
and give this video a thumbs up so you
never miss a the things upload
thanks for watching